cher journal je ne sais pas si je dois
tenir les hits
bon je suis un des six voilà toujours
peur de faire les mauvais choix
j'hésite soit te parler de mon dilemme
entre le dentifrice spécial blancheur et
celui spécial fraîcheur ou encore de mon
café que je ne sais même pas si je veux
cours ou allongés et ce t-shirt blanc là
franchement est ce qu'il n'est pas un
peu too much la couture et les hyper
voyante que les mains plus vite avec
quoi est ce que je vais bien pouvoir le
porter peut-être un jean brut
ah non délavé ce serait pas chez pas en
plus je connais une fille en a un qui
ressemble elle va penser que la copie
couche pas peut-être qu'elle sera flatté
c'est dommage qu'il n'existe pas en ai
cru je crois que j'aurais préféré ou en
crème
franchement faut dire qu'ils n'ont pas
beaucoup de choix dans cette veine là
quand même tiens j'ai trente jours pour
changer d'avis oh et puis allez tu sais
quoi dans un élan d'audace et d'
aventure je le prends je m'en fous on
n'a qu'une vie
ces 30 jours c'est notre contrôle c'est
dan où les indécis il faudrait qu'il
s'applique à tous tout le temps avec ça
je pourrais me faire recouvrir monde au
mythe à tout âge par un dessin
énigmatique qui susciterait des
interrogations auxquelles je répondrai
en disant que c'est personnel j'ai pas
envie d'en parler le dire quoi ce
personnage plus route 30 jours je me
ferais tu as trouvé un truc un personnel
dont personne ne voudra me parler
on peut en parler si tu veux et puis
j'attendrai le dernier moment et on me
dira que c'est trop tard et je pourrai
enfin regretté ce triste je vois
tranquillement enfin un jeu j'hésite
bon j'ai décidé d'arrêter d'être
indécise je me laisse juste trente jours
pour changer d'avis j'ai pas aller bien
sexy on la refait pas l'autre était
mieux qu'en pense je sais pas